-Our next guest is the Oscar
nominated writer and directo
behind films like
"The Sixth Sense,"
"Signs," and "Split."
His latest film, "Old,"
is in theaters July 23rd.
Let's take a look.
-You're 11, right, Trent?
-I'm 6.
-No.
Really.
Are you 10, 11?
-He's not lying. He's 6.
-I'm specifically
6 and a quarter.
She's 11.
-They're feeling unsafe.
There is a lot going on here
-They're playing with us.
Let's leave it.
-Have you seen my children
-Is everyone trying
to play a joke on us?
-What?
-Aren't these your children?
-I'm right here, Mom.
-Please welcome back
to the show M. Night Shyamalan
♪♪♪♪
Hey, buddy. Welcome back.
Good to see you.
♪♪♪♪
-Man. So good to be back.
-It's great to have you back
Things are a little differen
from the last time
you were here.
-Yeah, definitely.
I was -- You know,
I'm always a dramaturge,
so the structure of things -
I was like,
"Maybe Amy should go after me,
because entertainment value.
You want it to rise, you know?
So it's like --
This just feels like
it's a de-escalation somehow
I mean, I'm funny, but
I'm the Amy Poehler in India
I'm an Asian...
-Oh, gotcha. Oh, that's good
So if it airs abroad,
we'll flip it.
We'll re-edit it so that
they have that same feeling.
So, this is about an island.
A secluded island
where people age very quickly.
It's based on a graphic nove
that somebody gave you.
As soon as you were readin
"Sandcastle,"
did you think to yourself,
"Oh, there's a film here"?
-Well, it was given by
my daughters for Father's Day.
But they're very good
at picking material for me
that has kind of
darker movements
and kind of philosophy
behind it.
But as I was reading --
It's a graphic novel,
so it's very cinematic.
And I was like,
"Wow. This idea is amazing."
It's exactly what I'm thinking
at the time,
because, you know,
I'm the age I am, here, 50
and my kids now are adults
and my parents are older.
And I was like --
That's all I'm thinking about,
is, man, everything
is moving so fast.
We talk about that a lot.
-Well, it's -- You know,
I think that it's weird
because you internally
are concerned
and you have your own fear
about your own aging,
but then there's
that really scary thing
of just how fast
your kids grow up,
which is a big, you know,
thematic element of this.
Your kids are growing up so fast
that one of your daughters
was the second unit director
on this film.
-Yeah. Both daughters --
My oldest two daughters
worked on the movie.
One is a musician and wrote th
song that's key to the movie
and the middle daughter
was the second unit director
So we're at one end of the
beach, I'm directing here,
and she's directing
at the other side.
And she directs on "Servants."
So it's crazy.
And we'd have drinks afterward
at the end of the day
like work buddies
and talk about it.
-Do you -- Are you --
Did you know going into it
that you would have a good
working relationship
with your kids
if you were on set?
-I hoped so.
-Yeah.
-You know, our house
is very much the house
built on the arts.
Everybody's always talking
about the arts
and the good and the bad
of being a professional artist
And so the relationship
has always been that way,
kind of learning
about the art form.
It's worked out fantastic.
I mean, we share similar tastes,
I think.
So it was
surprisingly positive.
-You did this on a beach.
And so it seems
like very idyllic
and a wonderful place
to shoot a film.
And, yet,
you were sort of overcome
with not just issues like COVI
affecting production,
but a hurricane, as well?
-Yeah.
It was a tricky situation
to shoot in,
and we shot, obviously,
during the pandemic.
We were actually one
of the first movies to go,
if not the first movie to go
So we were making up everythin
of how to, you know,
manage in a situation like that.
And we were forced into
the hurricane season
of the Caribbean.
And a hurricane came
and destroyed all the sets
and we rebuilt it,
and three days
before we shot,
we were in rehearsals,
everyone flew there,
and there is no beach.
It is completely gone.
Road had gone.
They call me and were like
"There's no beach."
And I didn't -- I didn't kno
what was going to happen.
I pay for these movies.
So, these are small movies
This isn't Marvel.
This is like a --
You know, that's all we have
-Also, who do you call
to get a new beach?
-That was it. That's it.
That was our --
And, luckily, a little par
of the beach came back.
We shot on that, and then
every day it came back.
-Are you ever --
Do you ever think
or did you ever think,
"This feels like a twist
in one of my movies that the
beach would just be gone"?
-Well, shooting in a pandemic --
The pandemic itself felt like --
People keep coming up
and saying,
"This is like something
you write."
And I was like,
"No, I'm just pretending.
This is way too serious for me."
And so doing this in the middl
of that was scary.
And I think for us
as a crew and the actors,
it actually, you know, got u
in a certain place, I think.
And so when you see the movie,
I think a lot of the energ
you felt there is very specifi
to that time period
of our lives.
-You, of course,
make these thrillers
that are incredibly iconic
that play
with our fears
and our insecurities.
Some might think
that you are a man
without fear,
based on the subject matter.
But, you yourself --
For example,
you would not like
a turbulent flight.
-No, no.
I'm scared of a lot of things.
And as a kid,
I was scared of everything
My parents would always
have to make,
you know, precautions of, like
"Don't leave him alone,"
and this and that.
"He's scared of this sound
and scared of this."
And flights.
Just scared of everything.
I think -- I make these movies
I think to work through this
so I can be somewhat courageou
in the presence of other men
So, you know, just act normal.
-Another thing that I wonder
Does it take an inner courag
to act in your films?
Because you have a cameo
in all of your films.
It's something
that I always enjoy.
Is that something --
Do you get anxiety before you go
and perform in a scene
that you also have to direct
-Yeah, I mean, it's a
different part of my brain
but this is how I handle it.
I give myself
unlimited amount of takes.
So my takes, I do like 30, 40,
however many amount of takes
I need to do.
I'll take it
just to get one take
that has any kind of voracit
that's good,
and so I try not to let
the other actors see
how many takes I give myself
-Right, because then
they would want 50?
-Yeah, exactly.
-Do you -- Have you found
over the years,
when you look at your 50 takes
have you found like,
"You know what?
My earlier takes were better
and I made a mistake."
Or do you really feel like
"I warmed up into it."
-No, no. It has to --
It's almost, like, random.
It has to be by chance.
So I do 50 takes, and, like, 3
is the take that you guys see.
You just have to
kind of move through it.
There's no skill involved.
It's just, you know,
trying different colors
and then,
"Wow. That felt right."
-You -- Another sort of thread
that I feel like runs
through a lot of your film
is Pennsylvania's Philadelphia
And I always think that's nice
That's obviously
where you're from,
and you like to give it
a shout-out.
And I thought, "Well, this i
obviously not going to be
a part of this movie
that takes place on the beach.
And then, like, right --
Early on, somebody --
It's like,
"we're from Philadelphia."
Is that something
that you really --
it's important
for you to get in?
-Yeah. You know,
that's where I'm from.
I think, you know, the audiences
around the world
kind of look for that --
kind of it's from there.
And some authors
always make movies
about the place that they're in.
And this was one I guess based
on my feelings about vacatio
and things like that when
the family goes on vacation.
I'm like, "Everyone is so happy.
Oh, this would be a great plac
for something
horrific to happen."
You know, so you think about i
in those terms.
Every time everybody is
really happy, I'm like, "Hmm."
-And do you think the people
around you know that?
That, like,
when they're with you
and things are going
really well, they're like,
"Uh-oh, somebody's
going to make a movie
about something awful
happening here"?
-I'll look for a pencil
or something.
"What did you say?"
And I'll just say,
"Hold on one second.
You've never felt so much peac
in your life?
Hold on one second."
-"Open on..."
-Yeah. Yes, exactly.
-Well, congratulations
on the film.
It's always so nice to see you
-Thanks for having me.
-Thanks for being here,
as always.
"Old" is in theaters July 23rd